SURE YOU GET IT OUT.
>> Hannity: I WILL WEAR THE
YELLOW TIE JUST FOR YOU.
>> Laura: I'M LAURA INGRAHAM,
THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE"
FROM WASHINGTON TONIGHT.
SINCE THE RADICAL LEFT NEVER
TAKES A VACATION FROM HATING ON
ALL THINGS AMERICAN, TODAY WAS
THEIR ANNUAL HATE ON CHRISTOPHER
COLUMBUS DAY.
NOW THIS WAS THE TAKE FROM THE
ENDEARING FOLKS OVER AT SALON.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE ADULATION
THAT SOME AMERICANS BESTOW ON
CHRISTOPHER COLUMBUS WHO AS
HISTORY DEMONSTRATES WAS LESS A
HERO THAN A THUG EXPLOITING AND
ENSLAVING INDIGENOUS PEOPLES.
WELL, I BET A MORE SOBER
ASSESSMENT COMES FROM XAVIER
SIMONSON IN THE NATIONAL
CATHOLIC REGISTER WHO ASKED, ARE
WE THE BENEFICIARIES OF HIS
EXPLORATION GOING TO LAW DEMAND
FOR HAVING A CONVICTION,
AMBITION, AND COURAGE?
OR SHOULD WE BLAME THAT MAN FOR
ANYTHING THAT WENT WRONG
AFTERWARD INCLUDING EVENTS FAR
BEYOND HIS CONTROL OR EVENTS
THAT HE HAD NOT BEEN THERE FOR
WITHOUT EVEN TRYING TO CONSIDER
HOW HIS TIMES WERE DIFFERENT
FROM OUR OWN?
WELL, ON THIS 530TH ANNIVERSARY
OF THE DAY THAT COLUMBUS LANDED
IN THE WESTERN HEMISPHERE, IT'S
A GOOD TIME TO REMIND EVERYONE
THAT COLUMBUS DAY WAS A
PROGRESSIVE IDEA.
THEY CAME OUT OF THE NEW DEAL
ERA.
BACK IN 1934, FDR ESTABLISHED A
NATIONAL HOLIDAY URGING
AMERICANS TO OBSERVE THE DATE IN
SCHOOLS AND CHURCHES OR OTHER
SUITABLE PLACES WITH APPROPRIATE
CEREMONIES BEFITTING THE
ANNIVERSARY OF THE DISCOVERY OF
AMERICA.
WELL, OF COURSE, BACK THEN THE
PROGRESSIVES SAW EIGHT
ITALIAN AMERICANS AS LIKELY
DEMOCRATS.
BUT NOW THEY SEE THEM AS LIKELY
REPUBLICANS.
WELL, THAT'S REALLY THE ONLY
DIFFERENCE, AND A PROMISE HE
WANTS HISPANIC AMERICANS TIP
OVER 50 PERCENT FROM THE G.O.P.,
THE CANCELED CULTURE IS GOING TO
COME FOR THEM TOO.
NO MORE CINCO de MAYO FUN FOR
YOU.
WELL, THERE IS NOTHING THAT THE
LEFT HAS NOT TOUCHED, NOTHING
THAT HASN'T BEEN TRASHED, OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS, OUR CITY
STREETS, OUR COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES, AND SPEAKING OF,
HOW INSANE HAVE THINGS GOTTEN?
GET THIS, MEDICAL STUDENTS AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF MINNESOTA MUST
NOW TAKE AN OATH TO "HONOR ALL
INDIGENOUS WAYS OF HEALING THAT
HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY
MARGINALIZED."
SPEAK OUR INSTITUTION IS LOCATED
ON DAKOTA LANDS, TODAY MANY
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE CALLED THE TWIN CITIES
HOME.
WE COMMIT TO UPROOTING THE
LEGACY AND PERPETUATION OF
STRUCTURAL VIOLENCE DEEPLY
EMBEDDED WITHIN THE HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM.
WE RECOGNIZE INEQUITIES BUILT BY
PAST AND PRESENT TRAUMAS ROOTED
IN WHITE SUPREMACY, COLONIALISM,
THE GENDER BINARY, ABLEISM, AND
ALL FORMS OF OPPRESSION.
WE PLEDGE TO HONOR ALL
INDIGENOUS WAYS OF HEALING THAT
HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY
MARGINALIZED BY WESTERN
MEDICINE.
>> Laura: THIS IS MEDICINE
2022.
VERY CREEPY, WASN'T IT?
I WATCH THE ENTIRE THING.
OF COURSE IT'S ALL A PART OF
THEIR EFFORTS HAD DENIGRATE AND
REPLACE OUR OWN HISTORY AND SOME
OF THE MOST VENOMOUS DESTRUCTIVE
POLITICAL FORCES IN AMERICA
TODAY ARE LEADING THE CAMPAIGN.
SPEAK OF THE CITY COMMISSION ON
MONUMENTS RECOMMENDS THAT
CHICAGO'S THREE CHRISTOPHER
COLUMBUS STATUES BE REMOVED FROM
THEIR PUBLIC LOCATIONS.
THE STATUES WERE AT THE CENTER
OF VIOLENT RACIAL JUSTICE
PROTESTS TWO YEARS AGO, THE
COMMITTEE IS ALSO RECOMMENDED
REMOVAL OF TEN OTHER MONUMENTS
DUE TO DEPICTIONS GLORIFYING
RACIST STEREOTYPES AND WHITE
SUPREMACY.
>> Laura: THAT IDIOCY IS THE
RECOMMENDATION OF THE COMMITTEE
THAT CHICAGO MAYOR DARLING
LORI LIGHTFOOT HERSELF FORMED.
NOW SHE HAS NOT HAD TIME YET TO
DECIDE THE COLUMBUS ISSUE, BUT
SHE HAS HAD TIME TO RECORD THIS.
♪ ♪
>> Laura: THEY WANT TO GO,
THEY WANT TO GO TO FLORIDA OR
TEXAS, THAT'S WHERE THEY ARE
GOING.
ITALIAN AMERICANS WATCHING ALL
OF THIS, THEY ARE RIGHTLY
OUTRAGED.
>> WE ARE CELEBRATING NUMBER ONE
THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND
CONTRIBUTIONS ITALIANS AND
ITALIAN AMERICANS HAVE MADE
DURING THE DEVELOPMENT OF THIS
GREAT COUNTRY.
AND IT'S NOT JUST
ITALIAN AMERICANS, IT'S
EVERYBODY TOGETHER.
THAT'S WHY OUR PARADE HAS MADE
SUMMONING CULTURES IF YOU ARE
REALLY WATCHING.
>> Laura: LET'S REMEMBER THAT
THE DEMOCRATS ARE CLAIMING TO BE
THE DEFENDERS OF NORMS OF
DEMOCRACY.
IT'S USUALLY OF COURSE ONLY
RELATED TO JANUARY 6TH AND
DONALD TRUMP, BUT THIS HAS BEEN
A NATIONAL HOLIDAY FOR ALMOST 90
YEARS, ESTABLISHED BY A DEMOCRAT
ICON.
SO IF THERE WAS A NORM, WELL,
THIS WOULD BE IT.
AND AS FOR THE INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE, DOES ANYONE REALLY THINK
IT'S FAIR TO APPLY TODAY'S
STANDARDS TO SOME OF THEIR
ANCESTORS TRADITIONS.
FROM THE CANNIBALISM OF